hey guys how's it going if you can't
tell I'm I'm on vacation right now and
of course I've been spending a lot of
time editing and shooting videos for you
guys it is so nice outside gonna lay out
I just was working on a really fun
little project man that waterfall is
really loud things are happening over
here but also flying my drone taking us
in five taking pictures at the streets
you to keep them in pain now since I've
been traveling I'm thinking about travel
apps that I use when I trap there's tons
and tons and tons of travel apps I don't
really use that many specific travel
apps but when I am traveling I made
myself a little travel folder so I
thought I would show you guys what I use
to sort of keep my life organized keep
myself in check and basically things
that I sort of use on a daily basis so
as you'll see here on my first page
these are in no particular order I
basically just put them into this folder
just I could show you guys for the sake
of keeping it a little bit organized
I don't really actually ever go page by
page on my iPhone what I do is I swipe
down and I search for something so I
want to search for my JetBlue app I
search for JetBlue I'm not sure if in
the long run that saves me any time at
all but that's just sort of how I use my
phone and that's just CJ it's my it's my
thing okay just let me be going back
into our travel app I wish that I use
this app more it's called headspace it's
a meditation a for a while I had been
using it so I think I maybe did about a
month straight of using it I actually
did feel so much better
Amtrak I don't really use that often but
what I do need to I can book trips
directly on my phone Skype it this is
actually kind of a cool app as well
really I haven't used it on my new phone
because it's asking me to login but it
has really cool classes that you can do
on a treadmill not a big treadmill fan
I'd like to be doing something so I'll
either watch a show or I'll do one of
these classes they have really cool
music pretty fun FlightAware is
something that I use to track flights
Southwest another airline app Zillow is
actually kind of an addressing thing
because when I'm traveling I'd like to
kind of see what the real estate is in
the area Foursquare is really great for
getting tips on where to eat or coffee
shop I use Foursquare a lot for coffee
shops Virgin America
another airline JetBlue another airline
door - a food delivery service because
sometimes what I'm traveling I'm hungry
which is most of the time so I use door
- and post mates equally United just
another airline probably one of the
worst to be honest with you and then we
have audible which for those of you guys
who have used audible you guys know how
incredible it is basically audible is
audiobooks and as you can see here I
have Joey Graceffa as children of Eden
book up it's actually a really good book
and I was really surprised it has sort
of like that divergent trying to Hunger
Games felis to it either way Joey did
such an incredible job with this book
and I think you guys will absolutely
love it I'm sure most of you have read
it but if you haven't now would be the
perfect time if you would like to get a
30-day free trial and you can download
this book and many others you can use my
code audible.com slash iJustine and
basically you can take any book with you
on the go in Los Angeles traffic is so
bad so I always listen to audiobooks
because I feel like I'm actually
accomplishing something and getting
something done while I'm driving or
getting stuck in traffic because let me
tell you what you can't do you can't
drive and read a book but I have seen
people in their cars try to do that
audible.com slash I just seen it
yourself that 30-day free trial let me
know what book you guys gets and like I
said definitely check out Joey's book
it's so good it needs to be a movie
immediately next up we have poster gram
you can send post card photos right from
your phone to people's stores like it
it's like an actual postcard but it
comes from your camera roll results be
completely honest with you I haven't
ever used this kept trying to find a
fitness app to make me motivated and
want to go out and work out and I'm
still trying to find out motivation so
yeah
pokey radar for finding pokemon hiking
project this is a pretty cool app as
well especially if you're into the
outdoors it'll show you really great
trails in your area oh look
welcome to hiking project so we're
downloading 208 miles of trails in
Hawaii
I still can't pronounce this you guys
keep yelling at me Lufthansa loofah not
even gonna bother ATT passport that is
useful when I'm traveling abroad because
you can connect different Wi-Fi is that
AT&T has partnered with who
Translate basically helps you when you
travel internationally fly Delta
American both Airlines first mates
already mentioned that equinox the Jim
that I go to I use that sometimes if I'm
also traveling I can get a Guest Pass to
a local Equinox opentable for booking
reservations for restaurants prime now
is a service of Amazon so basically in
big cities you can kind of get almost
anything that you need within two hours
pretty incredible Amazon same thing but
not in two hours Yelp for food
recommendations thought I had some more
things on here other things that I do
use a lot of my phone clearly Google
Maps and Apple Maps a lot of people
still use Waze but I don't think Waze is
that good anymore
I feel like anytime I use Waze I end up
getting lost and it sends me down these
crazy directions and to be honest with
you booboo bought ways so you're still
kind of using Google so you might as
well just use Google the PlayMemories
app which is this right here I use this
a lot if I'm using my Sony camera
because I can connect to my camera via
Wi-Fi and I can get the photos and
download them directly to my phone in
that same note if I'm using my Canon
camera I will be using the camera can
and connect to also connect to my g7 X
or my 70d and I'll be able to download
all the photos and videos on the go
which if you haven't noticed most of the
photos on my Instagram right now these
are mostly taking with the DSLR so
that's I wish I could say it's taken on
iPhone 7 somewhere nope SLR look this
the g7 X took this the sony a7s to shut
this with actually on the edge without
the iPhone Sony I don't remember shot on
iphone I think this is a Canon EOS m3
this was shot on an iPhone this was shot
on a drone this was shot on a drone this
was I a screenshot from a video iPhone
anyway not only gone through my entire
Instagram feed let me know if you guys
have used any of those apps and if you
have any other recommendations for
travel applications because there are a
ton of apps out there that are travel
specific but I feel like some of them
aren't really 100% necessary but these
are the apps that I mostly use when I'm
traveling also if you guys do get an
audible book let me know be sure to use
the code audible.com slash iJustine and
yeah I guess I will see you guys in the
next video
okay guys have a wonderful time and look
for some more fun videos here I hope you
guys are enjoying the week of spooky
snacks
Halloween horror treats whatever we're
calling them I don't even know those are
super fun to shoot so I look forward to
possibly doing a Christmas version so
I'm gonna go cuz I am I'm sweating out
here in this t-shirt and my sweat pants
so bye I've already melted in here so
we're gonna get these started in our
little melting pot cut this open this is
just one big solid chunk
[Music]